all right let's get into audience
questions for the week first one hey
David why is the educational divide
among white voters not there among
non-white voters this is a really good
question it may be the wrong question in
a sense and I'll explain that in a
minute but first let's discuss what
we're talking about here we recently did
a story which looked at polling in terms
of Trump support and what you saw was
that among black voters black voters
basically opposed Trump by similar in
similar proportions regardless of
whether they did or didn't go to college
Hispanic voters are opposed to Trump
roughly equally between Hispanic voters
who didn't go to college and Hispanic
voters who did etc within white voters
white voters who didn't go to college
are significantly more likely to support
Trump than white voters who did go to
college so one way to ask it is why is
there an educational divide among white
voters on supporting Republicans the way
it may be backwards is maybe the
question is what is it about white
voters where when they aren't educated
they are falling for Republican talking
points but essentially we're asking the
same thing here now there's a few things
that aren't good answers one would be
it's merely about religion because if
you look at black voters black voters
are a pretty significantly religious
group they should be more conservative
than they are based on religiosity if
that was sort of the X Factor it doesn't
appear to be when you look at Hispanic
voters education doesn't become a
dividing line I believe because
regardless of educational attainment
Hispanic voters know that Republicans
don't have their interests in mind
they don't propose policies that are
good for them and Hispanic voters
regardless of education aren't likely to
fall for bogus Republican talking points
like the left is really the racist party
or whatever the case may be the
educational element becomes sort of
secondary with a lot of these other
groups with white voters the educational
differences become more of a dividing
line because nothing
else is bringing educated and uneducated
voters together on the same basis what I
mean by that is I've explained to you
many times before those lame Republican
talking points that don't work on
Hispanic voters regardless of Education
and they don't work on black voters
regardless of Education because they
understand the political realities of
the Republican Party those talking
points do work on white voters who are
not by virtue of their identity already
understanding Republican versus
Democratic policy and because they are
uneducated they're more likely to fall
for those talking points since there is
no other sort of insulating factor that
will protect them from it and this
becomes a self-reinforcing feedback loop
we're in great part the Republican Party
has written off a lot of these minority
groups they've written off Hispanic
voters and black voters and Asian voters
in many ways because they see that their
policy isn't appealing so they're
effectively doubling down and trying to
appeal to white voters even more that of
course leads to a bigger divide because
the white voters who are educated have
more of a framework with which to
understand and realize that they there
are attempts to bamboozle them whereas
the educated uneducated voters are not
so we have a combination here of a
self-reinforcing feedback loop where in
Republicans are particularly targeting
white voters and succeeding more with
those that are uneducated combined with
the reality that in a lot of these other
groups there is something else about
their place in the political milieu for
lack of a better term that reduces the
importance of what whether they are or
are not educated I mean as a very micro
level I know a lot of Argentinians here
in Boston I was born in Argentina as
many of you know and in the group there
are drastic financial differences where
there are people who are you know
effectively just entering the workforce
or have been in it for a while but earn
very little money are on social welfare
programs all the way up to medical and
legal professionals and successful
entrepreneur
etc and across that entire group
nobody likes Trump everybody understands
the role that Trump plays in furthering
the Republican policies that are not
good for Hispanic voters voters who are
immigrants from Argentina however you
want to define us many many Argentinians
are white as the term is and the
educational level and the class
differences that exist within the group
don't really seem to move political
views one way or the other if you looked
at an equivalent group of native-born
American born white people with such
drastically different class and
educational backgrounds my prediction is
you would see much more of a spectrum of
political views so those are some of my
ideas let me know what I'm missing a
very important question and an important
one to understand when looking at the
2020 election for sure